- As much as I love New
York City at Christmas time,
'cause I really do, I also
look forward to spending time,
like, even more so at my ranch in Montana.
I love it so much.
It's just so beautiful.
And look, I grew up with nothing
and I finally got something
that is so magical,
and it's awesome and it's beautiful.
And that's why I'm really excited about
the new Montana collection
by Kelly Clarkson Home,
exclusively at Wayfair.
(audience cheering)
I was so inspired by Montana,
I wanted to create something
that I love how I decorate there.
It's a reflection of my sanctuary
with ranch-inspired looks
and heirloom appeal.
Plus, these pieces are affordable,
which is super cool, and
designed for real life
to enhance any space in your home.
Today we actually have
another Montana lover,
which I'm very excited about in the house.
She is up in our Wayfair VIP lounge,
which just got some
new furniture and decor
from the Montana collection.
(audience cheering)
- Everybody say hello to the host
of "The Mountain Kitchen" on
Magnolia Network, Annie Starke.
Give it up.
(audience cheering)
Oh my gosh.
I love that you know my love of Montana.
- Hi, neighbor, what's up?
- I love it there.
It's beautiful.
- Oh, me too.
- Yeah, do you just love,
you're getting to work
there now too, right?
- I am, I'm so lucky.
And my whole family on
my mom's side is there,
so you know, we all went rogue.
It's great.
- It's so, you know why?
'Cause it's so beautiful.
I feel like it's like the
last unchartered place.
It's so beautiful.
So you have a new show.
It's called "The Mountain Kitchen," right?
- I do.
- What, do you cook?
Are you really good at cooking?
- I, well, you know, I don't mean to brag.
- Okay.
(audience laughing)
Do you like friends to come
over and test your food?
Because I don't cook, but I love eating.
- I do.
I have friends, I have
my husband, you know.
- Oh nice.
- Yeah, I, you know, I'm a
big grandmother basically.
You come in my house, I
need to feed you something.
- Oh my God.
(Annie laughing)
I'm like that Stovetop
Kid commercial, you know,
that just shows up at your
door right at dinnertime.
- Oh, that's weird. (laughs)
- Oh, you're eating-
- Well, come on over
for heaven's sake.
- Okay, sure, I'll come in.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I love it.
Do you love your new show?
It's so great, and, you know, it's such,
it's kind of a love letter
to Montana, you know?
- Yeah.
- Love letter to Bozeman and all that-
- I mean, it's one thing to live there,
I think people don't realize like,
oh my God, is that where you live?
- (laughs) Yeah.
And I love cooking with fire.
I always smell like smoke, honestly,
which some people don't like.
I kind of love it.
- I always smell like smoke
'cause we have a fire going constantly.
I'm not cooking.
I love that you do.
Thank you, Annie, for joining us.
(audience cheering)
All right, y'all, you can
catch "The Mountain Kitchen"
on Magnolia Network with
new episodes every Sunday
and streaming the same day
on Max and Discovery Plus.
I mean, hell, you just wanna
tune in just for the aesthetic.
That place is gorgeous.
And also remember to check
out the Montana collection
exclusively at Wayfair,
'cause I love Montana, so I was inspired.